wir wurden von ausländischen besucher
davon ist der führende astrophysiker
professor bremse überzeugt demnach war
das objekt humor das erste interstellare
objekt überhaupt ein von außerirdischen
gestartetes objekt und warum das erklärt
er jetzt in seinem neuen buch
außerirdisch intelligentes leben
jenseits unseres planeten also warum ist
humor außerirdisch das erkläre ich jetzt
hier bei klicks im future hier gibt's
drei mal die woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen beim live
ist beileibe nicht irgendwer er ist
nicht nur seit 1997 professor für
astrophysik an der renommierten harvard
university sondern dort auch noch
vorsitzender des fachbereichs astronomie
er spielt in der gleichen liga wie
stephen hawking spielte und hat mit ihm
zusammen auch das projekt breakthrough
star shop gegründet bei diesem projekt
sollen kleine forschungssatelliten zu
unserem nachbar sternensystem alpha
centauri geschickt werden um das system
zu erforschen erzielt von stephen
hawking und yuri milner einem russischen
milliardär ist das ein projekt mit dem
dutzende mini raumschiffe an riesigen
licht segeln richtung alpha centauri
geschickt werden sollen
milner hat es mit 100 millionen dollar
finanziert das konzept ein laser soll
seinen impuls auf ein nur wenige gramm
schweres licht see gegeben er schießt
von der erde aus und beschleunigt die
mini sondern auf die extrem hohe
geschwindigkeit von etwa 20 prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit trotz dieser hohen
beschleunigung wird ihre reise zu
unserem nachbar system
obwohl mehr als 20 jahre dauern die
sonnen selbst sind dabei im gegensatz zu
den licht segeln extrem kleinen test
sonden wurden bereits in den erdorbit
geschickt und kreisen in unserem
planeten es sind die kleinsten die in
die erdumlaufbahn geschickten satelliten
sie messen dreieinhalb mal dreieinhalb
zentimeter und sind damit noch mal
deutlich kleiner als die bisher
kleinsten satelliten die cubes die so
etwa ein kilogramm wiegen
dies preis so werden diese mikro
raumsonden genannt wiegen dagegen nur
vier grad denkbar ist dass die mini
sondern jeweils
unterschiedliche aufgaben haben werden
einige könnten fotos machen andere zum
beispiel daten aus der atmosphäre der
planeten sammeln
das größte element an diesen sonnen ist
jeweils das licht segel es muss extrem
groß sein um möglichst viel schub zu
entwickeln es würden ganz viele solcher
sonden richtungen alpha centauri fliegen
um dann im vorbeiflug daten zu sammeln
allerdings dafür hätten sie nur sehr
wenig zeit denn der vorbeiflug wäre bei
einer hohen geschwindigkeit von etwa 20
prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit sehr
schnell vorbei und ohne humor ändert
glück genau an diesen plan denn dieses
objekt hatte absolut extreme
eigenschaften dazu habe ich aber im loeb
interviewt das seltsame an diesem objekt
ist es weist eigenschaften auf die es im
sonnensystem so nicht gibt es ist sehr
seltsam es hat eine form die viel
extremer ist als jeder asteroid oder
komet den wir kennen und wir können das
sagen weil es sonnenlicht reflektiert
und als das objekt nah an der erde
vorbei gekommen war konnten wir
feststellen dass es alle acht stunden
einmal montiert und dass sich die
helligkeit um etwa den faktor 10 ändert
was bedeutet dass es mindestens fünf mal
länger ist als breit wir wissen nicht
wie es aussieht weil wir keine
gelegenheit hatten ein bild aufzunehmen
und so wie es sich beim flug durch unser
sonnensystem verhalten hat vor allem wie
starke sich durch den sonnen druck
beschleunigen ließ hat es eine länge von
20 metern und eine dicke von 0,3 bis 0,9
millimetern und alle versuche das durch
natürliche phänomene zu erklären sind
laut loeb gescheitert denn dass es sich
um ein neues natürlich vorkommendes
super dünnes material handelt ist
letztlich nahezu unmöglich und die
andere erklärung ist eben das ist eine
alien sonder oder die überreste einer
alien sonne sind und ist es absolut
unwahrscheinlich hier dass es
natürliches material sein könnte
insbesondere da es sich beim vorbeiflug
der sonne als perfekter reflektor
herausgestellt hat so schnell wurde es
beschleunigt hierbei gibt es jetzt zwei
thesen weltraumschrott einer fremden
zivilisation oder eine sonde die ganz
bewusst zu uns geschickt wurde um daten
über die erde zu gewinnen denn beim
vorbeiflug an der sonne beschleunigte so
stark wie das nur mit einem licht segel
geschehen konnte denn die gravitation
hätte dafür nicht ausgereicht und aus
wie bei einem kometen wurden auch nicht
beobachtet und die these dass es
wasserstoff ausgasung hätten gewesen
sein können ist laut lück auch unhaltbar
darf der sich schon vor der ankunft in
unserem sonnensystem verflüchtigt hätte
nur ein extrem dünnes material hätte
diese beschleunigung durch sonnenwinde
erfahren können eben ein nicht segel
zudem hat es so viel licht reflektiert
wie man es von einem metallischen objekt
erwartet zehnmal mehr als sonst
asteroiden und kometen reflektieren wenn
wir eine künstliche her kommt in
betracht ziehen so wäre eine möglichkeit
dass es sich um einen im interstellaren
raum treibendes licht segel als reste
eines fortschrittlichen technologischen
gerät handelt licht segel mit ganz
ähnlichen dimensionen wurden bereits von
unserer eigenen zivilisation angedacht
und entwickelt etwa von ikarus projekt
oder der breakthrough starting chips die
licht segel technologie könnte vielfach
etwa für den transport zwischen als dem
planeten oder sternensystem genutzt
werden so loeb in seinem buch ein
forschungsteam der indische tipp braig
solisten hatte damals sogar eine große
abhöraktion gestartet mit
radioteleskopen wollten sie den
mysteriösen brocken über mehrere
frequenzen abhören wo kommt um humor her
woraus besteht der sendete er signale
außerirdische intelligenz aber es blieb
alles ruhig
doch das ändert nichts daran nur bleibt
mehr als mysteriös und forschungsteams
weltweit suchen weiterhin nach neuen
erkenntnissen oder zumindest hinweisen
um seine identität zu klären denn es
sind mehr fragen offen als beantwortet
fest steht nur es handelt sich um das
erste interstellare objekt das nicht aus
unserem sonnensystem stammt und dessen
durchflug wir beobachten konnte nomura
ist das erste interstellare objekt das
eindeutig identifiziert werden konnte
wegen ihm gibt es jetzt eine neue
kategorie der internationalen
astronomischen union für inter stella
wir haben es hier also mit 1 i zu tun
und löw sagt zu 1 i
die alternative ist sich vorzustellen
dass humor moore auf einer
aufklärungsmission war der grund aus dem
ich über die aufklärungs möglichkeit
nachdenken besteht darin dass die
annahme dass mon amour einer zufälligen
umlaufbahn folgte die erzeugung von 10
objekten pro sterne unserer galaxie
erfordert diese fülle ist bis zu 100
millionen mal höher als vom sonnensystem
erwartet basierend auf einer berechnung
die wir im jahr 2009 durchgeführt haben
ein überraschend hoher überfluss es sei
denn humor ist eine gezielte erkundung
einer aufklärungsmission und kein
mitglied einer zufälligen population von
objekten die these wenn man natürlich
wäre könnte es eigentlich nicht
existieren weil dafür so viele natürlich
objekte durch das universum fliegen
müssten wie nicht zu erwarten wären da
ist dann für loeb eben nur noch eine
erklärung plausibel um humor muss eine
alien sonst an loeb geht aber noch einen
schritt weiter er vermutet dass es sich
ursprünglich um eine ganze armada
solcher sonden gehandelt haben könnte
und nur eine dieser sonnen es geschafft
hat wirklich unser sonnensystem zu
treffen bzw
wir nur eine der sonden entdeckt haben
sprich dieses objekt hat nicht nur genau
die maße die man beim licht segel
erwartet und die reflexivität sondern es
hat sich auch genauso verhalten es
müsste schon ein ziemlich irrwitziger
zufall sein
wenn ein objekt erstens so aussieht wie
ein sonnensegel zweitens seine
eigenschaften aufweist und sich drittens
auch so verhält und genau das ist löws
kritik was wäre wenn wir uns diesem
objekt genau so intensiv wie anderen
wissenschaftlichen fragen widmen würden
in diesem buch betrachte ich diese
beweise untersuche diese hypothese und
frage welche konsequenzen sich ergeben
würden wenn wissenschaftler dieser frage
die gleiche aufmerksamkeit widmen würden
wie der erforschung der supersymmetrie
zusätzliche dimension der natur der
dunklen materie oder der möglichkeit der
existenz von multi wersen solo und er
ist davon überzeugt das leben keine
ausnahme sondern die regel im universum
ist sind wir allein das ist die
grundlegendste frage in der wissenschaft
weil sie unsere perspektive auf unserem
platz im universum verändern würde
und mein ansatz dazu ist so viele daten
wie möglich über den himmel zusammen und
dies ohne vorurteile mit aller
zurückhaltung gesagt glaube ich dass wir
nicht besonders sind wir wissen dass ein
viertel aller sterne einen planeten wie
die erde hat ungefähr so groß und in der
richtigen entfernung damit flüssiges
wasser an der oberfläche und die chemie
des lebens wie wir sie kennen entstehen
kann
ein viertel aller sterne und wenn man
für ein viertel aller sterne soundso auf
würfelt milliarden mal milliarden male
dann ist es sehr wahrscheinlich dass es
primitives leben gibt mikrobiellen leben
aber vielleicht auch intelligentes leben
da draußen und wir sollten nicht davon
ausgehen dass wir die antwort vor der
suche danach kennen wir sollten
aufgeschlossen sein
ich denke dass wir nichts besonderes
sind ich denke da wir hier existieren
ist es sehr wahrscheinlich dass es
andere zivilisationen gibt für loeb
spricht also sehr sehr viel dafür dass
humor ein künstliches von außerirdischen
gebautes objekt ist die frage die sich
für ihn aufstellt war der besuch der
außerirdischen technologie zufällig oder
absichtlich wenn wir das herausbekommen
dann redet er sie erfahren und hier
erfahrt ihr noch mehr aus seinem buch
jetzt vorgestellt am 8 februar 2021
erscheint außerirdisch intelligentes
leben jenseits unseres planeten hier
geht's zum langen interview mit glück
abonnieren nicht vergessen bis dann
bleibt da